hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on Luke universe comm thank
you and enjoy so we know that LD L
functions to deliver cholesterol to the
peripheral tissues the question is how
does the LDL particle get cholesterol or
cholesterol esters into the peripheral
tissues well it's done by by receptor
mediated endocytosis and this also
occurs with VLDL as well as I do why is
it that it can work for them - well it's
because they have a PO b100 okay which
we'll see you actually pretty important
here so the LDL particle has cholesterol
and cholesterol esters and it has its
April P 100 protein and what's going to
happen is that the first first thing
that happens is that the the LDL
receptor the LDL receptors will
recognize and bind a bovie 100 so the
LDL receptors are these here in blue
these are the LDL receptors and they are
going to recognize and bind that a PO be
100 and what's going to happen that
what's going to follow is the
imagination to form the endocytic end of
cytotec vesicle and in this pit here we
have this this little protein that coats
the pit and that's that's a clathrin I
have these clathrin-coated pits
clathrin-coated bit and the imagination
to form the endocytic vesicles so that
we have the LDL taken up into this
vesicle here and what follows that is
lysosomes will begin to fuse with the
vesicle and basically hydrolyze it break
it up into all the components including
amino acids cholesterol esters
and other components of the LD L so what
can happen is these cholesterol esters
that are coming from the LDL that can be
converted into cholesterol by lysosomal
acid lipase okay to Cleve is esters in
the cholesterol now the cell had this
peripheral tissue cell has cholesterol
that it can work with
so this cholesterol could basically go
to whatever the cell needs whether that
be it can go up to the membrane to help
maintain fluidity it can give rise to
steroids it can actually even be turned
back into cholesterol esters via
recertification if we're trying to
simply store some of it okay
so the idea here is that this is how LDL
particles can be taken up by a cell and
how the cholesterol can basically come
off of it and how the cell can begin to
utilize it so I hope that video is
helpful thank you for watching thanks
for watching be sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and don't forget to share the
video of anyone who you think might find
it helpful thanks and happy studying